um I I'm just trying to not having
worked in investment banking or in
finance in general I would just take too
much time for you give me some more
concrete examples of the unethical stuff
just trying I mean why for example you
think you can take a company public for
16 to 18 dollars you tell them I can
take a public for 24 to 26 dollars that
happened a lot
the only people I didn't see do then
we're Goldman and and and if you've got
the right partner Lehman now why would
someone do that
okay number one fifty-fifty the market
might come back you might actually be
able to get it done in 24 to 26 let's
assume it doesn't come back 50/50 you
might be able to convince the the CFO
that in fact someone who wanted to be a
manager who wasn't at Torpedo the
offering 50 50 even if you couldn't make
him believe that that he'd still
eventually accept you back into his good
graces good they decided everyone else
is just as big a liar as you so what you
end up having is a series of mouth bets
that get you business and if you're and
if your real skill
unlike Goldman is in lying as opposed to
solving financial problems then your
comparative advantage is to lie okay and
then you'd say to yourself oh no we'll
see if both will share this no because
if you're CFO
you're supposed to be able to figure out
who's telling the truth and who's lying
and if someone takes advantage of you
advantage of you are you gonna spread
that around
no that also becomes a competitive
advantage because it's the same
investment banker is dealing with other
people in your business in your industry
your knowledge that's that their [ __ ]
ends up being something very valuable
and you're hoping the next guy uses them
and gets and gets toasted so there's so
you know there are certain business okay
and I've already accepted out this was
not the environment when I worked at and
all I think casually I'm accepting out
insurance I'm not making I'm just
talking about one element unforce
with with the demise of glass-steagall
these are the sorts of people that
started running our banks so we did
would take we took a small number of
venomous people and gave them a huge
amounts of assets to control